black cherry Nails will never not look
expensive they may be a classic but so
are perfectly fitting jeans and we still
love them like the name suggests the
shade mimics the dark color of black
cherries beautiful examples would be
Chanel's Rouge Noir bio sculptures Love
Potion opi's dark cherry Chutney CN D's
black cherry and Essie's Bordeaux it's a
neutral that goes with everything it's a
little vampy and it works perfectly with
the Moody color palettes of Autumn
winter wardrobes here's some of our
favorite ways to wear them short and
squoval short and rounded rou Noir Ultra
dark with skinny glitter Frenchies deep
red black cherry soft and square Ultra
glossy square tipped Deep Purple Inky
black short and straight edged square
tipped with Swirls midy and rounded
short and vampy semi- short black cherry
Chutney burgundy and wine colored